dalvin cook has been phenomenal this
year and even in a game that felt like a
down game peter king with 96 rushing
yards he still
was churning and churning and helping
the vikings balance out their offense
and keeping the chicago defense on its
heels long enough to give her cousins an
opportunity to throw the ball this week
the cowboys come to town with two weeks
to get ready for the game on a scale of
one to ten peter the cowboys
what number would you apply to the
cowboys using the bye week
to focus on stopping dalvin cook in this
upcoming game
13
but it isn't just dalvin cook it isn't
just dalvin cook it's alexander madison
who is
you know i think they drafted the
minnesota vikings in 2019 drafted
uh
you know the alter ego of uh
you know of dalvin cook this is a guy
who is as physical and as as threatening
a downhill runner
almost as as dalvin cook is and mike
look the reason the vikings are
different
is that they've run those two guys
together
had 99 rushes in the last three weeks
that
is mike zimmer football that's the way
he wants to play i think he is
deliriously happy with how the offense
has gone from being hey let's have
cousins throw it 36 times today too hey
we're fine with cousins thrown at 20.
let's win the time of possession keep
the ball from the other team and look
we all saw the other day
that the vikings you know didn't run the
ball as explosively it was more of a
plotting
old uh you know 1950s cleveland browns
type you know municipal stadium running
game for them it was ugly it was it just
wasn't wasn't the prettiness that you've
had in the last two weeks but mike the
key thing is they held the ball for 36
minutes
that is one of the things you do when
you have a dominating running game even
if they're not running for six yards a
carry as long as they are making that
clock run and keeping the other offense
off the field that's part of the design
cowboys defensive end demarcus lawrence
said at one point this week that the 307
rushing yards they allowed to the browns
back in week four won't happen again
well i should hope it won't happen again
and it isn't going to take 307 for
dalvin cook and alexander madison to be
the difference makers on sunday for the
vikings dolphins are six and three
they're at the three and six broncos
scale of one to ten how much of the
miami turn around do we attribute to
rookie quarterback to otango by law
three
it this is
the the miami dolphin even though two
has got a a a passer rating that's 10
points higher
than uh than ryan fitzpatrick's he
hasn't thrown an interception in three
starts that's fantastic that is just
what the doctor ordered that's just what
brian florey's ordered
but i think the revival of the miami
dolphins
uh is a is a defensive story uh they've
got so many good
young
um you know instinctive and and
impactful defensive players particularly
on that front seven
emmanuel ogba is finally healthy
and he's showing what he should have
been in cleveland early on in his career
but he was always hurt so to me i think
it's more of a defensive story mike
yeah i agree with you too i'd say
three's about the right range and
remember tua popped up on the injury
report this week with a foot something
to monitor as we get into sunday
steelers 9-0 at the one and eight
jaguars scale of one to ten what are the
chances we see the steelers sleepwalk
into jacksonville and possibly lose for
the first time this year
i think it's a one it's not impossible
because jacksonville
showed last week that they can frustrate
a good offense
miles jack in particular
uh was just an impact player at lambeau
field they came close to winning that
game the other thing that's interesting
is that this young quarterback jake
lewton is just
honestly he's he is almost and it's so
coincidental that he's this year's sixth
round pick right and that he is like
gardner minshew the second
and you know he's he's playing
competitive he's not playing great he's
not playing as well as at times minshew
played but
they're a threat i don't think they'll
win this game
but i don't think the steelers are one
of these play down to the level of
competition teams
they have had some wins this year that
should have been by a larger margin i
don't think it happened right the
jaguars there's a history there ben
roethlisberger mentioned that this week
you know the jaguars beat the steelers
in pittsburgh twice in 2007
twice in 2017 regular season and
postseason these teams used to be in the
same division together even though that
was before anyone connected to the team
currently was in pittsburgh but there's
enough there that they're not going to
step into a trap against a team like the
jaguars they're going to release the
opportunity to beat the crap out of them
if they can
patriots four and five at the two and
seven texans scale of one to ten the
chances the texans interim head coach
romeo cornell figures out a way to beat
his old boss bill belichick
uh three i think the only way this
happens is if it is if desean watson has
a dominant explosive game
and that means that you know his
receiving core has to come through for
him and beat the patriots and
that hasn't happened a lot this year so
to me i think that's one of the parts of
this week that
uh would be interesting to me desean
watson the game is i think very much on
his shoulders i don't think the patriots
are going to score a lot
but i do think it's possible for watson
to score a lot i think he's going to
have to score probably in the high 20s
or 30s to have a good chance to win this
game i don't see it happening but i
think they got a chance
i'm amazed the patriots are only favored
by two it makes me wonder what i'm
missing i'm going to assume i'm missing
nothing that's my favorite play of the
week for anyone out there who cares
patriots only giving two points at the
houston texans the eagles three five and
one the browns six and three scale of
one to ten your confidence that carson
wentz can turn it around for
philadelphia
two
i i don't know mike there's something
wrong with carson wentz
and uh i think it bleeds into almost
every aspect of the team right now you
know why does doug peterson go for it
down four go for two down four with 20
minutes to go
uh because he's trying to put light a
spark with his offense
and he's trying to just say hey i got
faith in you i got faith in you even
though what he sees every week says i
shouldn't have faith in you i shouldn't
have faith in you and
i just think that especially because
philadelphia has had so much trouble
protecting wentz they're going up
against the hottest pass rusher in
football and miles garrett
this is a bad match and a bad week i
think to play the cleveland browns
that's another one when i saw the lines
brown's only giving three points at home
to the philadelphia eagles the eagles
have played some good teams tough they
played the ravens close they played the
steelers even though it was a nine point
margin at the end of the day it was a
close game back and forth i just feel
like the eagles are broken and it's
something that they can't fix on the fly
until they get sufficiently backed into
a corner that they feel like they're
desperate and then like last year when
they were five and seven they rattle off
four in a row to win the division i just
don't think they're capable of pulling
that off
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports